tomorrow
you're all right boys let's rock and
roll
as someone familiar with the series Star
Fox zero is immediately confusing on the
surface it appears to be a modern
extension of starfox 64 but zero plays
by its own rules
it relies on the gamepad's display in
motion sensing capabilities asking that
you divide your attention between two
screens one for flight and one for
shooting which fundamentally changes how
you play the game zero has a few tricks
up its sleeves when it comes to vehicles
- including the Walker mechs
transformation for your are winged jet
you also have access to a slow drone
like copter in the gyro wave which packs
a tiny tethered robot that you can lower
and navigate through small spaces to
access computer terminals once lowered
you look through the robots eyes using
the gamepad screen to pinpoint your
target and hack away that was a process
that's more tedious than it is enjoyable
more than anything else in zero piloting
your AR ring is a joyous experience your
booster jet communicates a great sense
of speed as you twist in midair and flip
around behind enemies leaving bursts of
energy in your wake you also have to
contend with tight spaces tipping your
wings at just the right angle to slip
through small gaps and avoid
environmental perils
let's take the back way the landmaster
tank from Star Fox 64 makes its return
as well but new 2-0 is the ability to
transform the landmaster into a jet
though it doesn't match the speed or
maneuverability of the arwing it's a
welcome bonus that makes piloting a slow
tank tad more interesting in practice
most stages in zero are on Rails where
you move forward at a constant rate in
other scenarios typically boss fights
you switch into all-range mode and take
full control of your are way and it's
here where zeros complicated control
scheme becomes the center of attention
and not in a good way
now in theory zeroes controls allow you
to be a more capable marksman picking
off enemies with greater speed and
accuracy than before the catch though is
that you have to look away from your TV
and focus on the gamepad's first-person
cockpit view while your vehicle flies
unattended you have the option to press
a button to shift the cockpit view to
your TV but even so the same disconnect
applies though you may find some success
aiming with a third-person reticle when
flying through linear stages it's
actually terribly misleading rather than
indicate where your shot will actually
land the reticle and zeros third-person
view is representative of your line of
sight from the cockpit
once you enter all range mode you have
no choice but to switch between first
and third person perspectives here the
camera becomes unshackled and floats
around your vehicle rather than directly
behind it you're over the shoulder line
of sight is stripped away although you
can lock onto enemies that come into
view it's only the camera that's
effective not your aim and it took hours
to become fully acclimated to zeros new
rules but it did eventually click while
I still resort to feeling out my aim
during linear levels and more
comfortable and effective in all
arrangement the high learning curve was
enough to make me put down the
controller and walk away more than once
early on but every time I came back my
skills improved my relationship with
zero did get off to a rocky start but I
was in a better place once I convinced
myself to forget everything Star Fox 64
taught me and accepted zero on its own
terms now the new controls don't
necessarily make for a more fun space
combat game and I found myself wavering
between excitement and apathy when going
through the campaign no matter how you
slice that star fox has always been a
series about flight and movement and
zero dilutes that formula by forcing you
to prioritize shooting that's not to say
you never had to fire at enemies in the
past but the act of aiming was tied to
movement which in practice maintained
the ever-present joy of flight now the
act is tied to a complex control scheme
that's a mild
regular source of frustration
Zero's saved in part by its presentation
blue skies and verdant hills with
crimson enemies give way to vast
expanses of outer space the perfect
canvas for lasers and radiant stars with
the added gravitas from the soundtrack
and the quips from your allies during
battle zero often echos the Star Wars
films great battles albeit with a cast
of cute and furry heroes the old
material is handled with care and later
levels do a good job of standing out
with new mission designs and set pieces
that feature impressive scale by the end
of my first playthrough I was eager to
go back and retry old levels in part
because I wanted to put my newfound
skills to the test but also because
zeros campaign features branching paths
that lead to new locations my second
run-through felt way better than the
first and solidified my appreciation for
the game well I still don't love the new
control scheme it's a small price to pay
to hop into the seat of an arwing and
dive back into combat zero is a
good-looking homage with new secrets to
find and challenges to overcome it
doesn't supplant in Star Fox 64 but Star
Fox zero does the series legacy justice
you
you